it's time for scene and unseen where we
reveal the stories behind the headlines
for that we turn to Fox News contributor
Raymond Arroyo all right Ray Joe Biden
may have shown some desperation today I
understand
election desperation lawyer he's clearly
worried about talk of Senator Joe
manchin running on a third party ticket
Democrats are trying to discourage that
run and the president was sucking up
hard in the East room today
I'd like to thank Joe mancha's standing
all this time he's a friend and I want
to thank and I made a sincerely Joe
manchin of West Virginia to share with
us today as well
next you'll be having a Rose Garden
event in honor of Cornell West you know
my brother Cornell is here I mean it
sincerely look I'm wearing a scarf
Cornell anytime Biden says I mean it
sincerely he probably doesn't he's made
similar comments before
[Applause]
friends who voted for the law I want to
compliment all those mainstream
Republicans I mean if they get in they
fought like we usually fight
you know Laura anytime he says I mean it
he's worried and he's worried about Joe
manchin Joe manchin is the honorary
chair that no labels group they have a
lot of money and Mansion has till
January to declare whether he's going to
run for the senate or never going to
make it never gonna happen no Joe Biden
double crossed him on that drilling
remember but it's never going to happen
well as you know Laura pride month
celebrations reached a fever pitch over
the weekend now some of the displays of
public nudity were well LGBT negative
and while some companies are backing off
of their advocacy the Biden
Administration particularly Health and
Human Services are leaning into sex
change operations for the young today
they held a pride Summit the theme was
protecting our gains advocating for more
and boy did they this is secretary
Xavier bachera or Becerra and assistant
secretary Rachel Levine
when we come to work we understand that
Equity must Infuse everything we do I
have met with trans teens to find out
how we can serve them better I can
cut the kitchen
feeding
till age 26 I can't imagine waiting at
all
um for for most people that is not
waiting is not a possibility such an
important issue for our youth we often
say the gender affirm and Care is Health
Care gender affirming care is mental
health care and gender affirming care is
literally Suicide Prevention care would
that be your view as well I 100 percent
agree
Laura these surgeries as you've reported
on this show these surgeries are
life-altering they don't mention that
they're the other thing not being
reported here the FDA has not approved
not approved these puberty blockers for
use in gender dysphoria they're only
approved for other things so it's it's a
curious moment when the polls
particularly are moving in the other
direction 60 percent of Americans at a
Pew survey said the sector assigned at
Birth that is your gender I can't
believe it's only 60 that's depressing
um now what else what about the products
the celebs oh my gosh well look stars
have often sold products Laura based on
their brands Suzanne Summers sold by
Masters Emerald sells pots and pans and
Snoop Dogg sells a different kind of pot
he recently launched a cannabis brand
called Sleepy Joe you might notice it
that's Sierra that's dead serious that's
the product now another celebrity Maury
Povich is announcing a new home product
after retirement uh my business manager
Jonathan Lennox came into me says you
know I have an idea I said what he says
you are so well known about paternity
testing we can do a home paternity test
and I said
I'm in the name of the test is the
results are in
Laura if not paternity tests Povich's
other options were boxing gloves and
Brews cover up you remember those brawls
on the show when they revealed the
findings of those tests so God I guess
everybody's got to make a bug Raymond
he's so rich right he's
he's do you ever think
just enjoy your life I mean is this
really the one the way you want to go
out I mean you already did all that he
did it all he was the master of it he
and you know a couple of other uh shock
hosts on TV but come on you wanted in
your retirement you want to do something
for the good of others Laura maybe
paternity tests will do the trick we'll
see but uh we'll check it out don't
worry and see how the results turn out
and I understand he already has one um
customer and the hunter Biden oh well
that's the difference sorry all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else